when it comes to comic book movies it's
important to have a certain amount of
suspension of disbelief still sometimes
you can't help but wonder exactly how
some plot turns went down while Captain
America's Civil War was awesome from
start to finish there were some moments
that made us go hey wait a minute oh and
watch out major spoilers ahead blurred
vision the event that kick starts the
movie into motion is the battle against
crossbones in Lagos Nigeria which ends
with the villain attempting to explode
Captain America and himself to bits he
fails in his attempt thankfully when
Scarlet Witch ships the blast elsewhere
unfortunately her actions accidentally
lead to the deaths of several relief aid
workers you know who probably could have
saved the day
the vision who simply wasn't there it's
not like he had an exciting personal
life or anything so why was he absent
it's never explained but if we had to
guess it's because his presence would
have changed the nature of the fight and
prevented that part of the plot from
working no spin zone before unveiling
the sokovia accords general Ross takes
the Avengers for a guilt trip down
memory lane he reflects on the various
incidents that have taken place since
their inception as a team focusing on
the innocent casualties and damages that
happened as a result the Battle of New
York is one of the key talking points
although he avoids mentioning how the
world security council ordered a nuclear
strike against the alien invasion in
Manhattan which certainly would have
caused far more damage than the Avengers
did why didn't someone from the Avengers
speak up and point that out you'd also
think that someone on the team would
have noted that Scarlet Witch his
actions and Legos saved even more lives
by removing crossbones blast from ground
level which was much more populated in
fact pretty much all of the incidents
Ross mentions would have been way worse
without the Avengers intervening right
shouldn't one of the super people
mention
okay that's enough all about timing
since the events of Avengers age of
Ultron that led to the death of his
family civil war bad guy helmet Zemo
plans to destroy the Avengers by causing
their inner conflict disintegrating the
group from within what's confusing
though is that a lot of his plans seem
dependent on the sokovia accords and
they didn't even come into play until
well after his plan started right let's
just accept that he's fast on his feet
and adapted to the situation just like
this next situation
what if Ironman hadn't shown up so zimos
big plan all along was to tear down the
Avengers by turning them against each
other right when he shows Tony Stark the
video of his parents being slain by
Bucky while he was all Winter Soldier
mode tempers flare all around and caps
relationship with Iron Man goes up in
smoke
hooray for Zemo on the other hand what
was Ziva planning to do if Iron Man
hadn't flown in when he did it's not
like he had any reason to believe that
Iron Man was arriving it was a
spontaneous decision of course there is
one thing you can set your watch to it's
Tony making crazy disastrous spontaneous
decisions so maybe we'll just give him
partial credit on that one thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which plot holds we
missed